by the way I'm gonna give you a couple
of other names for these things because
you might see them in other places and
you can use whichever you prefer so far
I've been calling this Cartesian form
and this modern form okay the reason why
I've been doing that is because it's
kind of the most obvious one it's like
this is the one which has X's and Y's in
it
I'm thinking Cartesian terms this is the
ones with a modulus and an argument so
you call it Morag form right there are
two other names that are important for
these which you may see this guy over
here PI Y is called rectangular form now
it doesn't take you under occupation you
see why right because when you got X
plus iy the shape that you're Tracy got
is a rectangle okay just like when you
are adding complex numbers the shape you
trace out is a parallelogram well you're
getting a rectangle every time you think
about it in x + iy form okay this guy
over here is also called polar form
because when you think of coordinates in
terms of their distance and angle
they're also called polar coordinates
okay there's still coordinates just
still need two numbers but that's
another way for concerns okay excuse me
it's exactly right concentric circles
now how do we normally convert from
rectangular to polar form what do we
what do we actually do the first thing
we do is find modulus right so to find
the modulus by the modulus we remember
that okay this is my compass on my right
there's X plus iy over there which means
that ah here's the modulus the distance
from the origin and where x and y are on
this diagram X is the horizontal part
and what is that very coupon that's one
of the code the mix of wine after all
okay so we use Pythagoras near here
right we said this that was fight okay
and we only need to consider one case
because our modulus is the length right
so that's why we only have a positive
case that this was us how do I find the
argument what did I actually do
I had to write two equations right
you're allowed to write two equations I
wanted to compare real parts X is equal
to our course leader and imaginary parts
y is equal to R sine theta do you
remember that so in summary I send this
X ok and that's why by the way we had to
find the one goes first okay so far so
good but now we've done loads of
examples of these but the question
becomes just like an auxilary angle okay
why can't I combine these two why can't
I combine them why can't I say well if I
do this divided by this is yeah kind of
it is kind of earlier in the
relationship how I'm gonna try and show
you like what would you do from this
your next step would be okay I'll just
Chuck 10 MS in okay so I'll go that
should be to say expert Inuit tan
inverse of Y X and in for uncle and can
I ignore our excuse me now as it happens
even though our is one of the parameters
it's not the main one like Theater is
the main prem not it's the one that
takes me round and round and round and
round
okay so why can't I do this why can't I
do this well for starters I want you to
actually do this is that you can in some
cases I in fact in the case that I just
drew for you in case I'd just remember
you if I have like let's let's think of
some numbers okay so if I said Y and
root 3 okay tan theta because 1 over 3
who knows it's off their head and
inverse of 1 or 3 this is PI on 6 that
plan sees now if you reach for your
calculator I actually would like you to
reach you calculate you'll need it for
this if you go V equals 10 inverse R 1
on root 3 should go ahead I'll wait for
you to actually input it quiz inputting
to your calculator is kind of important
me now if you're in degrees mode and
will hand you a nice angle if your
radians married okay new subject the
decimal but you will start to recognize
that you like oh I know what that one is
it's like 0.5 blah blah blah blah okay
that's pilot 16 works out okay so
sometimes you can sometimes you can okay
but it doesn't take long it's a workout
where you can't write so this is only
sometimes okay I'm gonna give you a
really easy example that shows you quite
rapidly it doesn't work so draw me a new
corporate I can do a whole bunch of
image
okay now let's have a look at this now I
hope I heard at this point because I've
chosen easy numbers for you you can just
tell me right off no calculators
required what's the idea of this number
okay so 135 degrees or let's go readings
but okay it's 3/4 of the way to a hot
tub right 3/4 of the way so that is 3 PI
on for happy with that okay so let's try
this out let's try this with this
okay let's try see that equals 10 ok I
have an imaginary part of the top real
part on the bottom okay so I'm gonna
write that even though it's trivially
easy to look out I'm actually gonna
write the dump of its because it's kind
of important to my proof
what's the imaginary part and what's the
real part minus negative 1 ok so far so
good
so I know what 1 divided by negative 1
is it's one and then you reach for your
calculator and you say well okay 10
inverse of negative 1 quite happy to
tell by this platform okay now something
is come up very very wrong right where
is - pilot for - planet 4-5 what is the
other way
all right it's over here now let's think
about this for a second I know exactly
why is handed me this angle okay because
if they're 1/10 of -5 for me is negative
1 it works in the other direction okay
oh why does it work well 10 right this
this thing which actually started off
with a 10 is a periodic function right
we're in Radian mode what's the period
of the tan graph
it's pi radians it repeats every pi
radius you get the same odds on right so
that's why 3 PI and 4 10 3 platform is
the same that's kind of negative pilot
form right because they're off by PI
radians so that we have the periodicity
of tanta peg for this different airtime
okay but why isn't it giving us the
answer that we want why is it giving us
that one yeah okay you're almost right
you're so close to the awesome
tan inverse right tan inverse is
actually limited between - time - here
and hi on - you'll only give you answers
in here okay now why have they chosen
that Mike domain why have they
restricted it there we're gonna do it to
this in a little more detail when we
look at inverse functions they're to you
but it's not that hard to imagine what
is the Terr graph look like
it looks like this there's - pi - and
this pi ax - do you agree with that now
if I wanted to go like further this way
because where's 3 PI over 4 so you plan
for it it's like over here ok I'd have
to include this value where the domain
is not continuous cool I don't do that
why not just include this continuous bit
right now secondly and this is why I
wrote down this line do you see why that
lines important how it's really
important um what is what are the
coordinates of this point down here that
it's actually telling me this is not
minus 1 plus I is it it was - I do you
see why it has to be 1 minus I because
when you went from this line to this
line do you see the information has been
lost a tiny tiny bit of information has
been lost right
what information namely which one of
these numbers is negative right do you
see that this is the same as 10 inverse
of negative 1 on 1 do you agree with
that right like whichever way you divide
you still get negative 1 right these
will both come here but there's a
difference between the top the bottom
ones the imaginary part and one's the
real part there - completely
complex numbers but 10 inverse will give
you the same argument for both because
it can't tell the difference between
both of them do you see what's going on
right like this information here that
disappears when you actually do the
division right you lose out which wears
the same like am I am i over here or am
i over here okay so therefore this is
why you can't use tan inverse most of
the time where is the case where it
works have I given you enough
information to work out where what best
quadrants in first quadrant you are fine
okay because there's positive positive
so it's no big deal
right um you know positive positive is
gonna give you positive right do you see
doesn't why does it work in the third
quarter because their birthday it is
your birthday today which sends you back
to thinking you're in the first quadrant
right so you can see again the
information gets lost
okay so so you've got an alternative if
you are if you are dead set in city
insisted on using tan inverse okay which
by the way I'm going to give you a good
reason to do that in a second I don't
think it's necessarily like you know
it's the best bad way but still show you
why if you definitely want to use this
you have to make the argument that
you're up in this quadrant okay or if
you're not in this quadrant you know how
to get from this angle which is the
wrong angle
so the actual angle that you want
because we're taking a form already
tells you what quadrant you're in do you
see that like you're like okay I'm
positive positive or negative positive
or it tells me whether I'm one two three
or four okay so yes you can however I
would suggest that doing this is just as
fast and it's clearer as well and it's
simpler like it doesn't it leaves less
room for me to creep in like errors to
creep in because you're doing two steps
now where I was just doing one I was
just working on the quarter off of here
and let's say there's the angle straight
away and I don't need to take a lady
illegal and then add it to something
else or subtract something else okay